From day one, Shemar Moore's Derek Morgan
was the charm and muscle at the heart of Criminal
Minds.
He made it through 11 seasons barely that
included wrestling with bad guys and childhood
demons, not to mention being framed, kidnapped,
and tortured.
Finally, enough was enough for both the character
and the actor who played him.
Moore officially departed from the long-running
crime drama on March 23, 2016 in an episode
that saw his character's fiancée survive
a gunshot wound and give birth to their child.
And that was just two episodes after Morgan's
own near death experience.
Suffice to say that having a baby changed
Morgan's perspective on his career, and he
decided to step away from the action-packed
life and his colleagues in the Behavioral
Analysis Unit.
Since then, Moore has returned to both CBS
and the role of crime-fighting action hero
with a troubled past, playing Hondo on S.W.A.T.
But despite his talent for playing tough guys
who won't say no to a fight, in real life,
Moore's reasons for bidding farewell to his
most famous role are surprisingly similar
to Morgan's reasons for leaving the BAU.
It took eight years for flirtatious workaholic
Morgan to find a steady girlfriend.
As Moore put it to TV Guide,
"You never saw [Morgan's] off-the-clock side,
where he lets his hair down, dates, has drinks
and has somebody in his life."
In the first episode of season 9, the character
finally mentioned a girlfriend but it took
another eight episodes to meet the lucky lady
who would become his fiancée, Savannah, a
doctor at Bethesda General Hospital.
Moore can relate to his character's overdue
love life.
In fact, that's one reason he gave for stepping
away from the role.
A few months after his last episode aired,
he told TV Guide that he said goodbye to Criminal
Minds,
"... so I could pursue other avenues of my
life.
I want to get married, I want to have kids,
I want to travel."
A few years on, and it appears that unlike
Morgan, Moore has yet to find the person he
wants to settle down with.
He's been romantically linked to several famous
women since leaving Criminal Minds, including
soccer player Shawna Gordon, whom he dated
from 2014 to 2015, and actress Anabelle Acosta.
In 2018, he told Steve Harvey that he and
Acosta were taking things slow, while also
emphasizing that he was looking for a long-term
partner, saying,
"I've done everything I could do by myself,
and now I need that somebody I need that partner
in crime to do the rest of what I want to
do."
Unfortunately, Acosta was not that partner:
the pair split in 2019, and Moore's mission
to find love continues.
The other reason Moore gave for leaving Criminal
Minds was both personal and professional.
In that same TV Guide chat, he revealed,
"I'm just ready to grow [...] I'm not leaving
to go make a bunch of money [...] I'm leaving
because I just creatively want to be fueled,
and [I'm] excited to try new things and see
what else I'm capable of."
After departing from Criminal Minds, Moore
starred in the 2016 rom-com The Bounce Back,
which he also executive produced.
The film looked like it might be Moore's chance
to break the mold, as he went from portraying
an FBI Special Agent to playing an unlucky-in-love,
self-styled "relationship expert."
The Bounce Back received respectable reviews
from critics and audiences, but it ultimately
flew under the radar, and didn't make much
of an impact for Moore.
The actor also continued lending his voice
to the character of Victor Stone (a.k.a. Cyborg)
across several animated DC projects, which
he had done even when he was still working
on Criminal Minds.
"Good work, team!
Too bad Shazam and Lantern had to miss the
fun."
In 2017, Moore went back to television for
S.W.A.T., a remake of ABC's short-lived '70s
cop series that is still going strong as of
the making of this video.
Moore told CBS This Morning in October 2017
that his role on S.W.A.T. is his "dream job."
"This is my dream job because I've always
believed what I'm capable of.
I get to be a lead, which I'm proud of, but
I'm also smart enough and humble enough to
know that I can't do it by myself."
It was certainly sad to see Moore leave Criminal
Minds, but fans can take heart knowing that
he's happy where he is now, and will likely
be a prime-time mainstay for years to come.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.